>> Laura: THE HEADLESS
HOUSEMAN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING WHETHER THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ON THE VERGE OF
BLOWING WHAT IS TRADITIONALLY A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO PICK UP
SEATS IN THE MIDTERM ELECTION
CYCLE, YOU MIGHT BE ONTO
SOMETHING.
NORMALLY THE PARTY IN POWER
LOSES SEATS IN THE CYCLE
FOLLOWING AN ELECTION.
SO DEMOCRATS THOUGHT PICKING UP
DOZENS OF HOUSE SEATS WAS GOING
TO BE PRETTY EASY.
ALL THEY NEEDED TO DO WAS TO RUN
AGAINST TRUMP.
NATIONALIZE THE ELECTION, ON THE
HOUSE MAJORITY WOULD BE THERE.
BUT NOW, THEY MUST CONFRONT OR
TRY TO DISTRACT FROM TRUMP'S
STELLAR ECONOMIC RECORD.
NOW THEY ARE IN A DIFFICULT SPOT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO CONVINCE
VOTERS TO VOTE AGAINST THEIR OWN
POCKET BOOKS THIS FALL.
THAT'S A TOUGH CLIMB.
BUT LET'S ASK A FEW FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS HERE.
WHAT IS THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
AND WHO WILL LEAD IT?
MASSACHUSETTS DEMOCRAT
CONGRESSMAN SETH MOULTON
ADDRESSED THE QUESTION ON MSNBC
EARLIER TODAY.
>> WHO IS THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
THAT'S WHO SHE ASKED.
>> DOES MY SILENCE SAY
SOMETHING?
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW, I DON'T THINK
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
PELOSI, ALL DUE RESPECT TO HER,
AND SAYING HERE IS THE FUTURE OF
OUR PARTY.
>> SO WHO IS THE FUTURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
HE'S ON THE STAIR.
LET ME THINK, CALIFORNIA
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS >> IF YOU
HAD TO BE STUCK IN A ELEVATOR
WITH EITHER PRESIDENT TRUMP, OR
JEFF SESSIONS, WHO WOULD IT BE?
>> DOES ONE OF US HAVE TO COME
OUT ALIVE?
>> WHAT ABOUT NEW JERSEY
SENATOR CORY BOOKER?
>> WHY IS IT SO DISTURBING FOR
ME, WHY AM I FRANKLY SEETHING
WITH ANGER IS TO MARK YOUR
ASSIGNMENTS IN YOUR AMNESIA IS
COMPLICITY.
>> Laura: HE'S VERY ANGRY.
WHAT ABOUT MASSACHUSETTS ON HER
AND HER ELIZABETH WARREN?
>> MY AUNT BEA HAS WALKED BY
THAT PICTURE AT LEAST A THOUSAND
TIMES AND IT REMARKED THAT HER
FATHER HAD A HIGH CHEEKBONES
LIKE ALL OF THE INDIANS DO.
>> Laura: OR JOE BIDEN?
YES, I SAID AMTRAK JOE BIDEN WHO
IS TOURING THE COUNTRY ON A BOOK
TOUR.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOD LOVE YOU, WHAT I'M I TALKING
ABOUT?
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR
DUNKIN' DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
>> I WISH YOU WERE IN JUNIOR
HIGH SO I COULD TAKE HIM BEHIND
THE GYM.
AND PUNCH HIM IN THE MOUTH.
>> Laura: I WAS IN THE CAR
EARLIER AND I WAS SCREAMING
LAUGHING WITH RAYMOND.
IF YOU ARE IN A BAD MOOD, WATCH
JOE BIDEN ON YOUTUBE.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT TRUMP USES
VIOLENT RHETORIC, BUT BIDEN IS
ALWAYS READY TO PUNCH SOMEONE
ELSE.
ROBERT SCHWARTZ IS REPORTEDLY
MULLING A MOVE INTO POLITICS.
>> IT CONCERNS ME THAT SO MANY
VOICES WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ARE GOING SO FAR TO THE
LEFT.
I ASKED MYSELF, HOW ARE WE GOING
TO PAY FOR ALL THESE THINGS IN
TERMS OF THINGS LIKE SINGLE PAY
OR PEOPLE ESPOUSING THE FACT
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WILL GIVE
EVERYONE A JOB?
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET AWAY FROM
ALL OF THESE FALSEHOODS AND A
START TALKING ABOUT THE TRUTH
AND NOT FALSE PROMISES.
>> OKAY BUT THERE'S ONLY ONE
PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRATS.
HAS BEEN SPEAKING TRUTH AND HAS
BEEN DELIVERING REAL PROMISES,
AS PRESIDENT.
NOW HE IS CONNECTED WITH THE
FORGOTTEN VOTERS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS NOW SEEK AND HE HAS
ACTUALLY MADE THEIR LIVES
BETTER.
TRUMP'S REAL CLEAR POLITICS
APPROVAL RATING AVERAGE IS NOW
AT 44.6%.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT ITS LOWEST
LEVEL IN 17 YEARS, AND THE RCP
POLITICS AVERAGE ON THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY, THAT
THE COUNTRY IS GOING IN, IT IS
UP TO NEARLY 40% UP FROM 27% TWO
YEARS AGO UNDER OBAMA.
SO ALL THAT'S LEFT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO PRATTLE ON ABOUT
OUR ALL THESE SIDE ISSUES.
THE CABLE NEWS CATNIP,
IRRELEVANT TO THE LIVES OF MOST
PEOPLE.
BUT DO AMERICANS REALLY CARE
ABOUT WHETHER A CABINET
SECRETARY BOUGHT A USED MATTRESS
OF THE TRUMP HOTEL?
OR WHETHER JERRY KRISHNA GOT
SECURITY CLEARANCE OR THE
ENDLESS SPECULATION ABOUT THE
WHEREABOUTS OF THE FIRST LADY
AFTER SURGERY?
IF YOU ARE LIKE MOST PEOPLE, YOU
CARE ABOUT POCKETBOOK ISSUES.
YOUR SAFETY, AND YOUR CULTURE
AND DECLINE ALL AROUND YOU, AND
YOUR CHILDREN.
ALL THE THINGS THAT TRUMP IS
FEARLESSLY ADDRESSING AND
WINNING ON.
SO THE LEFT GRIPES AND MOANS
ABOUT THE ONLY THINGS THEY HAVE
LEFT TO THEM WHICH IS BASICALLY
THE SMALL STUFF.
IT'S MEANT TO DISTRACT THE
PRESIDENT AND LURE HIM ONTO
THEIR TRUTH
TURKS.
THEY WILL NEED A NEW GAME PLAN
IF THEY ARE GETTING TO THE TWO